guys this show is sponsored by better
help if you're thinking about starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule visit betterhelp.com DPT today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com DPT
population
welcome back you've done Studio versions
you've done live versions of this show
this is the cutest version I think I've
ever done adorable Town's really nice a
lot of people neon's hard to find but
somehow you guys attracted neon is one
of our most precious reasons one of the
seven neon stores near my house yes yes
congratulations crazy that none of those
stores have neon signs to promote
understand how expensive it is why would
they you don't you don't spend the
company money 82 of all businesses in LA
are just uh money laundering is that
what it is don't you think I don't know
if there's something with like a real
estate I like that as like a mo though
you go like 73 of people if you say it
if you start with the number one don't
you think you're like wait I thought it
yeah I thought you just said it you said
it I'm just out here you're implanting
this is how misinformation there's a
Peruvian restaurant by my house no one's
ever walked into or out of the person
yeah it's always open and it's behind
the 7-Eleven
they're just money's going in and
money's going out it's my favorite
restaurant
it's a Peruvian restaurant slash Pokemon
card thing I hope so Machu pics okay all
right let's stop it shall we get into a
story because the world's getting Dumber
shall we at least all right and we'll
talk about Neil special which Jason I
saw the we saw it live in Montreal we'll
talk about it later
somewhere later all right you ready here
we go this one's sent in by our good
friend Jake caroney we have a few people
to send it Patrick
the way to do it is just at school
Brothers at Daniel Van Kirk on Twitter
yes we're still on Twitter it's
ridiculous I don't even know why uh and
then hashtag dumb people town and then
it's in an order and we have a backlog
of stories you ready Greenfield woman
accused of stealing a certain amount
we'll we'll guess that amount but you'll
tell us how much
don't you think [__] 87 8 700
bucks accused of stealing a certain
amount of money from corn stand over
several weeks so this is like a a plot
like someone still has a corn stamp yeah
where are you from
don't worry about it okay well I don't
know if this will be related I'm just
here to podcast bro I'm not here well I
don't relate to this
outside Philly okay I don't know if they
have this outside Philly they have a
board stand corn a lot of places where
it stands and on your honor System
whether it's like firewood or vegetables
in the can yes
the only time I ever saw one was in Peru
if you want to go back to the Peruvian
restaurant the giant corn with the very
thick enormous like that was a yeah
driving up to the cabin in Wisconsin you
pass at least a dozen of these whether
it's firewood or fruit I think it's
small communities it works because
people are like they they feel reassured
there's an honor places where their
might still be 100 or they'd eat it they
need there to be honor they're like this
is basically all we got because that we
can trust each other but they still need
to yeah they everybody we need honor to
too we just don't have anything that's
the problem they for them this is like
I'm gonna drop my Dollar in and this is
what's keeping us from The Purge in this
moment and this woman is trying to bring
on the person she's like I'm gonna now
take advantage of that right this crazy
woman Hancock County Indiana a
Greenfield woman I love that Hancock
County Indiana but this woman is from
somewhere else she's like I'm going to a
different County to go to different
counties too that's right she's Crossing
county lines can that be like in the
band fence over six dollars in corn
which I will find out a Greenfield woman
is accused of uh taking money uh from a
self-serve corn stand sure over several
weeks so that's the other thing to me is
that this wasn't just a I got this idea
right now this is a plot over time
several at least five if I just take a
little bit and she doesn't need it to
survive right like we don't know
resulting in a substantial loss for the
business owner alleged court documents
the police investigation began on
September 4th when the Hancock very uh
Sheriff's still never forget 9-4 we'll
never forget where it was the owner told
police that she runs a self-serve stand
with her family and again the people are
like this is the question that they have
to ask themselves do we continue running
a self-serve stand or are you running it
are you technically what the thing is
the amount of don't animals get to it I
would think that I would think that the
amount of like fencing and maybe
Electrify the fence yeah and then maybe
you hire a security guard and then you
just have a store just you should have
just opened up in a store get about one
sniper trained on
far away that's right we can't see it
you think no one right it's Bradley lift
up your thing
what was that movie American Sniper yeah
I'm really surprised
American Sniper I mean I signed me up it
was on it was on target all right so the
owner told police did she runs
self-serve stand with her family in
front of of their home on the country
road of 600 North put that on the
walking tour uh this if anybody lives
near this you've got to go and take
pictures what state are we in this is in
Greenfield Indiana
Hancock Hancock County yeah yeah
all right uh the stand works on the
honor System with customers expected to
leave cash inside them in the mailbox
all right so Theresa Kenner according to
uh a probable affidavit the owner told
police caught a woman taking money so
she's V you gotta guess video it right
that's what that's what Neil's saying a
lot of infrastructure you need to have a
self-serve right corn stand so you're
giving your it's a 30 cent value of the
thing you're right people are exchanging
for yes just just open it just Walmart
Hiro worker putting someone there yes
and if this ends up being a lot of money
that means your self-serve stand was
doing great you want to do the over
under on how much money it will be oh oh
I work a project
what do you think it was probably ten
dollars
ten dollars a dozen I'm gonna say that
these cheat case this joint I'm going to
say 2 000 bucks two thousand what do you
think yeah I'm gonna think it's a lot I
think it's like six thousand dollars I'm
not we're just gonna keep all that and
then we'll get to it later I'm crazy but
I might be right from a porn economy
what are you where are you from over
several weeks if it depends on how you
said 16 there's no way the owners would
be wrong promise of this show dumb
people I know but affidavit in court and
[__] like court dates taking this woman
let me just say that like it's about the
principle you said 16 you said two
thousand you said six thousand one of
you is exactly right
what it's me you think it's you 100 do
you think it's you I think it's me yeah
dude you know what you know I think you
stumble down do you think it's you yeah
yeah let's do it you know I think I all
right give us the answer right the
answer is two thousand dollars
damn it so do I know the premise of this
show
it's more it should be what Neil said
all right so the owners that's barely
enough for a dozen years of coins the
owner put the woman's photo on Facebook
that's when you're like I have no other
recourse but to get someone's Racist
uncle involved let's put it on Facebook
that's like Interpol for for dumb people
it is dumb intervals in some communities
that's that's made it to the diner
before you even go yeah that's like
that's literally what Facebook
Marketplace you've seen this like that's
what someone walks in they're not even
holding up a paper you've seen this and
they know what they're Facebook yep the
owner told police Kinder herself uh told
police kind of herself called her this
just came through on Facebook
breaking news printing out Facebook
pages that's great that's number 13. and
ask for her picture to be taken off so
this so she chimed in called the owner
so Kinder called the owner who put it I
can't be having my name be smirched on
Facebook why are you put my picture on
Facebook and again I think again the her
accusing the owner of doing something
wrong coming in hot is like gonna try
and throw around any relationship you've
ever been in if you get into a fight and
they call you on something you did wrong
you fight fire you double you you make
it about something else yes yes
what most good relationships are built
around it is the basis of every great
relationship probably never heard of it
idiot right so she reportedly ASL i g h
t i n g she reportedly denied taking the
money at first and then told the owner
she returned how much money back in the
bin so she's like I didn't do it and
then she's like you know what I returned
actually I took it and then returned how
much
exactly this is what this is about how
many beers you have tonight sir one two
one two Mike my kids went to a party and
they were like recently and I was like
how much did you have to drink no like
one and then later as I am talking to
them later I was like okay so how many
times you have them chained to the
radiator yeah just know I'm like later
we're kind of so how much you have yeah
two two
you just gotta keep talking yeah keep
the conversation going then it's like
two beers in a tree leave the room your
wife comes in good cut bad cop good cut
look dad's been on one level I don't
know what's going on just tell me the
real number and then he won't come back
and take it like she comes back tell me
the truth now three beers and two
trulies I'm like
all right so uh how much did she admit
that she put back in the bin
this crazy 300 bucks okay what do you
think I think like 500 bucks and she
thought she was a saint eleven hundred
dollars
so she's okay because then she goes I
didn't even keep a thousand You're Gonna
Learn so much about her when I tell you
how much money she admitted to the owner
that she put it 90 bucks
this woman naughty this woman is
thinking she's getting oh my God two
thousand dollars and she's like I get I
put how the [__] are what
if it's sweet corn season and they're
putting it out there every single day at
around at least ten to twenty dollars
depending on I don't know Indiana taking
corn on the grill all right you grill it
up and you get some of the you know dark
grilled chard marks on it yeah you know
cut it off okay into a frying pan with
butter oh yeah a little salt garlic salt
on it and you make this very delicious
plate and you sell it for two thousand
two thousand dollars at a nice at like
the French Laundry on laundry that's two
thousand all right so they say that they
counted 18 instances from August 28th to
September 3rd where she allegedly took
corn from the stand and then helped
herself to the money by August 28th to
September 3rd that's one week yeah 18
and two thousand dollars two thousand
dollars that's once they could hired two
snipers yeah that's once they set up the
camera right you could pay a sniper 50
bucks X [__] Marine I want to go get
50 bucks to knock this like shoot into
Joe Rogan Security on the side shoot her
hand off just shoot her hand off you
don't have to kill her like 24 hours
security let's see how good of a marks
with benefits like not they only work 25
hours a week they're fresh Dental this
is gonna be a name drop Randy and I had
a meeting with Steven Seagal once
um he comes into the meeting
finds the chair like a chair that he
thinks in case he has to pounce which is
what he said he needs to chair in case I
need to pounce coming with him is like a
five foot seven
German guy doesn't speak a word of
English strapped with a backpack no it's
a backpack that should be on the back
front like on parachute yeah but also so
he can have exactly still the wrong way
out of the relationship but I mean and
we're like that guy how many guns are
grenades he has guns and grenades
there's [__] in there this is the guy
and I guarantee you Seagal wasn't paying
him anything 50 bucks a day maybe he
just want to train you'll train you life
lessons Priceless that's right I can't
put a price tag on the life lessons he's
given this also the the the the joy to
play with the toys right so like you're
saying 50 bucks a day you could get a
sniper to take out so this is what the
police said I watched the videos and on
all of them security videos you can see
what happens to be what appears to be
Teresa Kleiner come up grab the corn
place in a plastic bag uh and then but
her put her hand in the mailbox with the
money and on some occasions looked like
she was making change oh yeah she's
going through the motion like I didn't
even notice the camera there right oh
the old like oh yeah yeah great it might
have magic it doesn't make a little
thing in one video the woman can be
heard
look at her stuff
what's on a [__] green visor green
Vibe she has a changed belt yeah exactly
really going for it
she said she don't even know the corn
stand three times in 2020.
every one week right she told police
that her picture was on Facebook falsely
accusing her of stealing it uh as after
the uh she's most concerned about it
yeah no no so after the questions uh
question continued investigators say
Kinder told that she might have that she
might have dementia so she got
questioned enough I don't believe this
I'm telling you I do she said I might
have dementia I might have dementia how
would you know can I tell you all
something that yes you know that's what
she said before she said yeah
do this twice already I don't know
there's no way for me to know oh my God
sniper
this is where you hire Seagal's German
guy to snipe the hell out of this owner
said after looking the numbers they
believe that the total loss of missing
cash and corn so they're going to put
corn in corn and cash together yeah I
should have told you that was around two
thousand dollars but could possibly be
more well of course if she hit 18 times
in a week and that's only when they
videotaped her she'd been hitting this
for a while so she was charged with 18
counts of theft I'm gonna show you her
picture and then we're gonna figure out
how old are you we get the guesser age
after we look at her no I love it
because sometimes it makes so much fun
sometimes the picture I know it's going
to be white so I'm very confident 100
Contour about the age okay so this is
and we'll put this on our pinch Zoom
there you decide if she has dementia or
not just looking at her I mean what do
we think okay she is you know uh she has
she was a leader of the cult where
everyone put the purple shoes I don't
think she'd be the leader I think she'd
be the right-hand woman the right like
the enforcement like they called her
mama OSHA
oh sure
doing a law doing lawyer he's like a
lawyer ocean uh no the lady oh the woman
yeah the woman I can't remember her name
I want to say Rita but that's not why
you're in the Wheelhouse yeah your
direction that gal she was like great I
mean nuts and the oh God she was
ruthless ruthless she's still doing it
Sheila very good I was like Rita Sheila
something who's like a woman who used to
work in an office in 1986. the front
office woman talked to Rita about it
how we guess how old this lady right how
old do you think she is 66 years old in
her 50s she hit it he didn't give me a
number
58 okay 66 58 I'm gonna say 62. one of
you or we are one year off one of you is
one year off so you go up or down you go
down to 65. okay 63. 59 59 okay get your
answers in town it's first story down
the bus we're gonna talk about Neil
special right after the break this gal
Theresa Kinder stole nearly two thousand
dollars or maybe more of corn and cash
definitely smokes
all right we'll be right back with more
dumb people down and Neil Brandon right
after this
[Music]
hey y'all welcome back to the show uh
y'all I might have dementia we may have
said this before but in case we didn't
uh Neil Brandon has a beautiful special
uh it is uh stand up one-man show it's
got we saw it at a four or 500 seat
theater in Montreal and the best thing I
saw at the festival yep I loved it so
much for when you ran it at moon tower
too right I think so yeah without the
problem with that right the wall is
beautiful oh and you said like though
they [__] up the wall when we did the
thing that we did there was like one oh
yeah yeah they screwed up it didn't
matter it was beautiful it's called
blocks and then there was a subsequent
podcast called block subsequently
yeah turns out I'm making a podcast so
it's a b it was you know it was what I
loved and I told you about this at like
the after party but I'll just say it out
into the world right now is that
it was like one of those shows a one-man
show done where the comedy is on the
absolute highest level of the stand-up
bits and whatnot but it was fun to watch
you take your time and not have to like
dance what else what else dance for a
stand-up audience and actually take your
time and talk about what's behind a lot
of this stuff to me was like that was
equally as fun and deepening and it was
just really cool I was like this is such
a great way for you to present what our
brilliant stand-up premise is but then
to go deeper into the stuff and of
course mental health being a backdrop of
it I was like this is so relevant so
good so I'm very excited that it's
making its way out to the world it's on
Netflix and it's
um yeah it's out now it's out now and
the podcast so the blocks mean like
things that make me feel like
something's wrong with me like yeah I'm
an emotional box mental blocks whatever
right and uh so I have other people come
on the podcast and tell me what their
walks are and that's been great because
it's people that I don't like I know
Sebastian pretty well but I don't know
like what his problems are oh I love the
clip where he's talking about blocks of
people that have pictures of them oh
yeah like why we have of people who have
one of his boxes he doesn't understand
people have uh paintings of themselves
in their own house of themselves uh
Letterman did it uh Nikki Glazier did it
Taylor Tomlinson Bobby Lee was great so
I've had good people on and uh and yeah
it's it's yeah so I got a special and I
got a I got a a podcast I love it I and
and it's worth watching again like I I'm
gravitating more towards this type of
performance in general I we love stand
up and we're way into it but I like
seeing I like seeing it pulled out we're
old and we're contemplative people now
we are we I think that should be a part
of it as we are starting to figure out
what is the next thing that we do with
this current hour of our stuff I we saw
your show and we're like oh that's very
inspiring and maybe there is sort of
whatever is important to us and version
of what we're doing that would fit into
that for us people have a more of an
appetite for
interesting [__] like everyone does
stand up yeah they can get stand up
anywhere so if you give them like stand
up plus a little something else and also
once you frame it that way it gives you
that permission to not be like I haven't
set a joke in a minute and a half yeah
we were like what the [__] is going on
but once you step away with it it allows
you that that's what I mean barbically
like that's yeah he was like well I'm
gonna I went to um
I went to his opening night uh here in
town yeah
I did too I think okay yeah and I looked
around the room right and it was all of
our friends and all these people you
know and all and I thought to myself
this is the difference between theater
and stand up because if this was the
night of his special being taped yeah it
would all be his we'd know we would
support and we would love him but we'd
tell everybody in the world from The
Mountaintop to go see Mike's thing I put
I post a story yes but we'd come and
hang backstage maybe hey I'll be there
at the airport what time are you guys
doing it I'll try to swing by but we
wouldn't go to the show but once you say
that and and I felt the same way about
your suit it's it's oh this is going to
be an artistic expression Beyond just
stand up yes we already do yes and so I
want to see how what this person's
theatrical interpretation of their words
are like what the [__] are you doing the
other part of it it's like what the [__]
yeah yeah exactly there's a lot of that
but nobody will go to a special but
everybody wants to go to an opening
night of a show
and you feel like a cool you feel cool
it feels sophisticated it does because
like a sticky
a reputation which it needs a little bit
well but yes yes I agree I agree with
that you there are if we go up with you
at The Comedy Store we go up in the main
room still and you follow like
Headliners and you follow people who do
a whole character and a schtick and a
big thing and a lot of people come see
them and you do have to step up and you
have to deliver jokes on a pretty rapid
basis it's hard to like 100 take your
time and just like oh your payoff
if your payoff has to be miles Beyond
whatever this weird slow burn one I
always say if you get one of those don't
hit them right away in the first 20
seconds
at The Comedy Store if you don't accept
if you say anything unfunny they will
never forgive you they're done yeah you
like you just are gonna waste 15 minutes
of your time that's right and part of
the reason they're done is because they
know you aren't going to be up there for
very yeah you're 15. you don't have to
reinvent oh good I'm going to run to the
best person they're coming to see is
maybe after you yeah yeah and it's very
dark in the room and there's no like why
would I even be nice to this person
that's right 100 on accountability
anyway super psyched about blocks blocks
podcasts blocks the special I love it
Daniel people can see you Dana Vancouver
yeah go to danielvankirk.com uh I got my
monthly that I do in Houston where I'm
also working on new stuff and then Irene
two and I have our show at the lyric
Hyperion theater it's a lyric Comedy
Hour every Wednesday I'll be at moon
tower again this year doing uh stand up
and shows I think we're gonna do a dump
people down there we're gonna do another
one that was so fun that we did with you
last year
may uh April 21st to the 21st there's
one weekend
in the last weekend but uh it was great
to see you there last year oh yeah so
fun and we're gonna do tag it that show
that we do do you ever do that show with
us yeah it's so fun when you stand up
and then we just pitch you a bunch of
we're writing tags and whatnot it's so
much fun we might actually start doing
that at The Comedy Store like up in the
belly room and then kind of working and
then say to people who are like you who
are coming to do a set like come bring
up like eight minutes you're working on
and we're gonna just write tags for you
great it's basically the [__] around
part on stage after the set is so fun
with you so it's basically taking what
we do in the hallway up to the belly
room like outside so we might do that so
anyway superstars.com check all that
stuff out and again I'm still waiting to
hear if we're going to do another season
of the nosebleeds which was like a
little cheap seat show for ufcs
people town
this show is sponsored by betterhelp and
we can't be happier about that because
we are all therapy people my wife is a
therapist we've all benefited from
therapy it can get you through really
difficult times in your life and it has
for me as well as transitions in your
life as you're making changes in your
life therapy is a wonderful sounding
word and way to help you of course
Getting to Know Yourself can be a
lifelong process you know that Jay
especially because we're always growing
and changing a different person now than
you were in your 20s and your 30s Dan is
a different person now than he was 45
minutes ago that's right exactly and
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want
that's right or why we react the way
that we do absolutely we need to talk
things out better help connects you with
licensed therapists who can take on you
on that journey of self-discovery it's
very important you know I mean the great
thing is too is like we all hopefully
have friends
um but they're not you know trained to
be able to talk to you about the stuff
that you're going through your life or
the stuff that you went through earlier
in your life or the stuff that you are
starting to go through and so for me
personally having a therapist is having
a place to put whether it's the
day-to-day frustrations or the big arcs
in my life that I find challenging and
having that place there with an
objective person who can listen and give
me you know qualified professional
thoughts and responses is like the best
best part of it let me say this to you
if you're thinking about therapy at all
or starting therapy give better help a
try it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited for your
schedule all you got to do is fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge right Jay there you go discover
your potential with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com DPT today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
help.com
DPT get 10 off your first month we
believe in it guys and we know you will
too
[Music]
number two sent in by Matthew Friedman
at not your average Matt AVG Matt thanks
buddy um here we go
a man died after eating a bag of black
licorice every day
so I'm getting older and I like black
are you for real admitting that [__]
that means you're old this is a sign of
you I like fernette but that doesn't
like it as a kid did you hated it as a
kid and something happened to your mouth
I think it's like physiological yeah
like what happened in your mouth it's
like you know like someone has like a
stroke and then they can speak Italian
that's sort of what happened with like
black licorice for me and I raised two
kids and ate black lives and I raised
these goddamn kids and all of a sudden
I'm like what's this and I
it has
to be it can't be
um like stiff and like It's gotta be
really cheesy chewy and fresh
while you're cheating that's fresh
how fresh is that licorice I want it I'm
not saying but Jason's over here
printing out Facebook pages I'm in a
group called black Jay will be chewing
on his black girl and telling me about
Colonial pains I'm in a Facebook group
called black licorice matters and here
look that's what it is
I love it so much and it is you know
what you love it I love it and I was at
Gelson's
okay drop and I was like I'm getting
this I'm getting this for my house get
your hands off me I'm no no I'm getting
this and knowing that no one else in my
house how much is it you reach for it
and three people come with sir that's
very much oh I was gonna say once you're
much older Once you walk up with black
licorice they they assume you do not
want to mess with self-checkout right
like you don't understand it they're
like oh that's not for you yeah sir do
you have any kids you want to use uh
Rosemary my 92 year old grandmother
loves black licorice I'm your
grandmother that's who I became she
would recommend the Trader Joe's which
is what I buy her Jay you're the
matriarch of a thing
I think it's okay I wouldn't reach for
it ever I mean give give me like a weird
when did you even bump into it so I
think I had it tired no 10 a.m
retirement party this is the only it was
in a it was in a basket at something
either a comedy vessel or something I
broke it out because I was really hungry
the ARP comedy committee
I cracked it open I don't know what it
was there for I tried it and I was like
wait a minute do I like this now who am
I anymore
and then I'm like you know what I'm not
gonna fight this it's like weird it's
like you know what yeah by the way
that you like someone putting a thumb in
your ass this is Jason's episode
I love you but have you ever spoken to a
psychic before and had any work done
with the psychic ever yeah so I am it's
not something I pay for myself we turned
50 last year and someone got it for me
as a gift I'm like this is the best it's
the best most indulgent it's at a party
somebody left it it's at a party someone
hired a tarot card but I love that
Jason's having his own like a black
licorice version of an Ayahuasca trip
this is who I am as a person this is my
[__] Burning Man
no but I so I when I talked to the
psychic at the beginning I didn't want
to give her too much because I just was
like I want to see what this woman comes
from sure but I said let me just tell
you from the jump I do not believe that
this is going to work however I'm
open-minded enough that I hope something
happens yeah just because if it does I'm
not going to deny that it happens so
James able to receive the energy Jay was
open to received the spicy why do we
have to have why do we have to say no to
this based on the fact that it's black
would you eat a bag every day so that
you die like this dumbass no I did my
worry for you this is now a cautionary
he had no history of heart problems he
walked his dog regularly and worked a
physical demanding job as a construction
worker according to his doctor so same
thing as me this is my life so no stress
whatsoever I mean construction is about
as easy well I think we're gonna end up
they kind of lay some stuff in here
they're like sure it was a black liquor
we'll get to it then in January 2019 he
collapsed at him McDonald's and died
well okay first of all he's at a
McDonald's not driving through inside
there walked in yeah so I think we go
there's a window into his life he had
just dropped his Triumph in the garbage
and was going back a second
yeah he brings his own but blame
blackler they're always blaming black
stuff they are he brings his own gold
ash tray that got rid of him 25 years
ago like you're sitting in there like
David do you want the usual like that's
how much McDonald's knows this guy you
guys remember the gold ash trays of
course yeah yeah it was always bent out
of it absolutely you probably were
meeting there for coffee with your
friends talk about the war no never
smoked I spoke for 10 years wow how'd
you first of all
did you do the book was it the book The
hypnosis made me quit yeah yeah no I
just decided I had to quit that's great
it's very Carlin and I like quitting
things yeah I like like creating
separage no relationships no that
especially I know
so yeah I like like white knuckling yeah
I like going cold turkey I like that's
my favorite kind of turkey you like
black licorice no hot turkey for this um
and
um and yeah so I quit wow that's my wife
used uh hypnosis to quit and it and it
worked she's she's described it to me in
a way of like
you know I go to a party and smoke but
then after she did the four sessions of
hypnosis with this guy Carrie Gainer who
was here who's like done it for a ton of
people every time she hears a car honk
she jumps out a window like besides that
she doesn't smoke a weird side effect
that's okay but uh no but she's sees a
cigarette and she's like oh wow
disgusting yeah just just that he did it
on his own that's um I hypnotized myself
wow but you did mentally just shut the
door and then left because if I smoke
one I'll smoke forty thousand so just I
just said well this guy who do people
offer you have they offered since have
you been around in a party and been like
I haven't seen one yeah people yeah
they're sick I live in a world with
cigarettes yeah but when people smoke
I'm still like you smell it's so crazy
to me yeah that's amazing that you put
that idea in your head
um okay so he's in a McDonald's which
I'm sure has nothing to do no that's all
black people
see McDonald's just walking like this
right yeah yeah uh we just found him
checking for black licorice so likely
culprit they say black licorice
according to the doctors treated him and
who published their findings in the New
England Journal of Medicine what the
report said the man from Massachusetts
had consumed one to two large bags of
licorice a day
for how long how long do you think it
took him yeah I'm not there yet how long
do you think it took him one to two
large bags every day for how long before
they say it killed him at what point
does he go from just Jason
I'll guess first I'm gonna say 10 years
10 years were you gonna say that I was
gonna say nine years say you do it nine
it's fine okay I'm gonna say 15 years 15
years we popped off I'm uh he consumed
one to two the cause of his death is
reportedly after consuming one to two
large bags of black licorice every day
for three weeks that's it that's it wait
hang on a second that
I mean I do obviously I'm gonna keep
doing it dude I have a good life
insurance black licorice as like an old
person's Black Mirror yes it's on the
Hallmark Channel and it's all technology
that's already out but that they don't
know how to use it also if this wasn't a
plot on Murder She Wrote I don't know
what was also I don't fault you for
doing this or if you're not watching
this show on YouTube Neil transformed
into a Sith Lord
um
on and my hood is up and it's black
you're gonna leave him I feel like the
Acoustics on my mic have changed 100
they certainly have changed in my ears
the reason why it got colder is because
when we start talking about black
licorice spirits of old dead people just
now enter together and walk through the
studio
of eating black licorice for only three
weeks caused his potassium levels to
drop precipitously wow prompting a
cardiac arrest according to the study he
never regrained regained Consciousness
after his collapse and died about 24
hours after he arrived at Massachusetts
General Hospital maybe this is what to
happen to Demar Hamlin we almost didn't
we almost asked our brothers we almost
didn't believe it when we figured it out
says Dr Jacqueline B Henson yeah uh heir
to the Henson we were shocked and
surprised uh aspiring doctors are taught
in medical school that black licorice
exactly as it is definitely a 90s sitcom
that never materialized first after
living single Jacqueline cancel
you know how the hands to me
baby Hansons uh aspiring doctors are
taught in medical school that black
licorice contains I'm trying
glycyrusic I don't know yeah acid a
plant extraction Henson keeps asking if
we can be friends on Facebook for sure
how do I know you we have three mutual
friends but how do I know you yeah and I
was hey Neil exclamation point yeah I
got it I got a great opportunity
I got a great opportunity for you miss
you miss me when were we ever seeing you
again when did we see each other uh it's
a planet we gotta catch up that acid we
got it it's been too long it's often
used as a sweetener and candies and
other foods and can lead to dangerous
low potassium levels if consumed in high
enough doses but it is rare to see a
case of someone dying as a result of
ingesting too much the candy so at what
is the point of putting that in the New
England remember they're telling you
yeah the only reason he died but they go
on to say the man in Massachusetts had a
poor diet and smoked a pack of
cigarettes a day okay
like I like the idea that the New
England Journal medicine is like all
right we need a fun one let's go with
like a fun story
like go with a wacky one cool math
General see if they got any things up
the butt okay like that yeah we know
that everyone knows about smoking we
need to bring this one out yeah let's
bring the poor diet they smoked a pack
of cigarettes a day again it's all on
licorice though according to his friends
and family I just want to ride on this
black licorice let's go but it was a
switch from red to black licorice three
weeks before his death the doctor said
prove fatal I on record have never liked
any form of licorice really as a kid
I've never like Twizzlers stop you
literally have to stop I'll stop I'm now
concerned I'm like you gotta stop but
you're more concerned for the career
yeah yeah
you guys are licorice guys I assume are
nibs still a thing they are still a
thing and they haven't been canceled for
that name that's a doesn't it feel a
little something if they started at nibs
please can
uh so let's see where did we say this he
was doing cigarettes and cigarettes bad
food Dr Henson Said She interviewed the
man's friends and family members
ran multiple laboratory tests that
confirmed the man's potassium levels
were below normal the study oh they also
studied his medical history which
included heroin use okay but again again
this is not was he shooting the black
licorice in his face this is my life to
a team freaking out you got to stop all
of it the heroine smoking with the black
licorice first yeah okay yeah yeah
that's the gateway to all this other
[__] keep the black tar heroin did
heroin
what what was the study of his medical
history which included heroin use they
thought that he they and though he had
not used opiates for three years I would
still say it's probably secondly very
hard
congrats to him for getting over it but
who knows about him for convincing
people that it's black licorice
yeah it was black licorice
don't look any further like the onion
headline is man man with Heroin
addiction dupes the New England medical
journal reticent that it's licorice that
is very true uh there's no family
history of cardiac disease we had no
other clear cause for why his potassium
levels were so low so we picked one that
was stupid the case quote raises a
public health issue that consuming large
amounts of black licorice can be
hazardous to your health one of them
said one of the authors of the study
done Dr butala said consumers need to be
informed of the buy the candy and other
food manufacturers of the level of this
acid in their products he also reported
the case to the Food and Drug
administrator operation the FDA warns
people who are 40 years old or older you
better stop Jay that eating how many
ounces of black licorice a day for at
least two weeks can cause heart rhythm
or arrhythmia wow you can really wait
I'm gonna ask you so they say how many
ounces
if you eat it for two weeks you can have
arrhythmia how many ounces a day are
they telling you do if you're eating
this many you can send it with harder 12
ounces 12. you know jump in with us guys
I've been wrong all day I believe in you
I believe in you but it's going to help
the hood will help 20. okay I'm gonna
say eight ounces well two ounces that's
it two Jay you are [__] dude you
better stop eating this is Jay's
intervention that he did yeah you gotta
stop eating the black licorice I know Dr
Hunt said people like to eat licorice uh
occasional piece of licorice should not
be alarmed by the case it's not a poison
Jackie B Henson and said thank you next
they're gonna if they go after hard
candy these [__]
how about tiny Root Beer Barrel candies
you're I mean the werthers that start
out crunchy on the outside and then have
a soft caramel inside yeah they do
whatever they want as long as they're
old people Reese's Pieces am I right old
people is he right we gotta hear this is
he right how old is the Massachusetts
man that died from too much licorice
he's still working Chase destruction I'm
gonna say 58 okay
a 67. to go with the people not looking
at the evidence 119. we'll get out of
here here and then we have to hold this
beer in the world dies of black licorice
the Massachusetts man who uh kicked
heroin I I hope it seems but still love
to eat at McDonald's and smoked a pack
of cigarettes a day sure and worse
construction was like asbestos
but we're going after big black licorice
right
he cleaned up super fun sites
I've worked at Three Mile Island yeah
yeah was there on 912 to help yeah
exactly uh he was
54 years old wow what did you say I said
58 wow what'd you say 119. I had a 60.
Jason's up for our three there we go
Jake give us a little taste of what
we're talking uh in segment uh a dude uh
on his honeymoon does do things to the
highest degree okay
uh Neil Brennan special which is on
Netflix is called blocks in his pot
subsequent podcast is also called blocks
check all that stuff out you can do it
in the break subscribe to it in the
break put it on your I love this and
send Netflix a message saying it's a
great please send this message we'll be
right back with more dumb people town
and Neil Brandon right after this
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show I'm
gonna bring us home here's the headline
Last Story man arrests
all the way home I have black licorice
in the car um
man arrested during prostitution sting
snuck away from sleeping wife on
honeymoon I mean that's bold he didn't
get a bachelor party maybe also where
are you where are you honey but not that
you can't like find prostitutes or sex
workers anywhere I mean anywhere this
was sent in by Jank Gyllenhaal at snake
that small batch underscore you don't
see a lot of underscores following the
name just a flat out on the name of the
service no this is our this is
underscores should have never been
understood I'm gonna go on the record of
saying are you going to underscore that
I can't underscore that I can't
underscore that what was underscore
serving before handles on the internet
what was the use you used to underscore
something important but that would be
honorable you go under the words
serving grammatically maybe it was for
like fill in the foreign
a thing where you're not allowed to do a
space
so you needed that to fill yeah
I don't know who knows stupid all right
here we go what is it at this point
right right
what am I hold over from dos yeah what
did I just brand a woman volleyball
tournament what am I
speaking of dogs you dare bring this is
where my Cove is yeah don't you dare
bring Keith Urban you leave him out of
it and his giant glasses that are too
big for his face but his perfectly sized
headband yeah yeah yeah well that
headband Works did you ever hang out
with people when you weren't laying down
on a couch like also put some [__]
shoes and socks on you monster and like
you know that like karch Karai probably
got a phone call like for Steve Timmins
I'm doing two Olympics
what was his name uh
they get a phone call and it's like what
about
that's how much he's ruined you know how
Cosby ruined the colorful sweater
folks you guys go on YouTube this is
gonna be worth it just for that joke
Cosby ruined the colorful sweater for
everyone but me these Keith Murray
ruined volleyball all right police in
Florida Sandman was arrested during a
prostitution seeing while his honeymoon
looks like a Cosby store that you
bleached yeah he is like you're trying
to whitewasher look I'm trying to make
it I'm not throwing away 110 dollars I
mean come on because of God only because
30 women got sexually assaulted I mean
what am I supposed to do I didn't do it
staying on his honeymoon as his new wife
I gotta suffer yeah D I want you wanted
to get married I won't tell you how old
he was we'll guess in the end allegedly
thought he was going to meet someone to
pay for sex but instead was met by an
undercover police officer so he's mad
that he got caught
I was just gonna meet a woman to have
sex I didn't realize it was going to be
a sting now I've created such shame on
my family if this wasn't a Sting If the
dumb police wouldn't have tried to sting
people everything would if I know women
she'll only stay with them for another
four or five years I was gonna hope for
the other one and be like honey at least
you can get in at home it's very easy
right is she saying on some level I can
fix fix him I can pick him
uh according to the Hillsborough County
Sheriff's Office which operates in an
area that includes Tampa Florida so now
we know where we are we know honeymoon
part of over how many arrests that
that's exotic in the honeymoon to me I
think like if you're going to Tampa you
live in Jacksonville so in our world
like in our neighborhood you live in a
tunnel right sure Alabama in Pensacola
people [__] on Mackinac Island in the
Dells way better than nothing that's
nice Tampa has a z like 68 degree water
oh yeah
uh so in our neighborhood when the cops
need money they just put a cop you know
down behind the Country Store on Laurel
Canyon and then
on a canyon yeah I don't want to say
which one no and uh come on yeah
and I heard we thought like I haven't
seen someone get pulled over in so long
oh my God on the way here saw someone
I've seen a ton and I think that's just
how they do it in Florida they're like
get out the prostitution ring yeah I
want you guys to guess how many arrests
were made by the department of human
trafficking Squad in the Miami Herald
reported this in this ring in this ring
that they were in this little run how
many people did they arrest 134. oh I
was gonna go 119.
one I was gonna go 119 34. come on give
me a guess
110. 110. get your answers in
they this this man was this morning was
part of a 170 arrests wow in how long
probably in a day not a day no no in a
couple weeks but yeah maybe a month they
set up a little task for unbelievable
Sheriff little task force a little some
cute little outfit
windows down in the car and let's drive
and go windows down AC on a little
Photoshop let's drive over here we go
and August 25th news conference Sheriff
chronister walked out onto a stage with
easels holding up in large displays with
this grid of mug shots of Arrested do
you think they just cropped his save the
day
it was unclear if any of the people in
the mug shots on display had been on
trial or had retained a lawyer that
doesn't feel it's a little weird civil
rights issue I don't know if a call was
placed to the Hillsborough County
Sheriff's Office but details about the
cases weren't immediately available for
release citing ongoing proceedings they
displayed the name mugshot alleged
details of the man arrested on his
honeymoon and the full screen of the
Department's press conference Saturday
and posted on Facebook so of course the
wedding already happened you're in for
the so that's why she's going to stay
with him for a little because they
already spent the money on the wedding
and she's in too deep She's In Too Deep
I can fit them listen to this Phil
Collins song as well here we go
chronister at one point there's the
sheriff Corona sir during the press
conference spoke in a Stern tone and
said quote he's pissed if you want to
traffic another for sex if you want to
purchase another individual for sex well
you want to prey on the children of our
community go to another County so he's
not even saying don't do it just he
doesn't like it around I don't want to
have to deal with it this guy's an idiot
it's not I mean I appreciate what he's
trying to do
it right just don't work for us I
appreciate what he's trying to do about
this we didn't change we we changed we
didn't share this right because the odds
are against you that your photo is going
to be on one of these boards he says too
many double negative
uh we're gonna get out of here on this
okay how old is the man
produce left his sleeping wife on his
honeymoon to go pay for sex and it
turned out to be an undercover cop under
25 or over 35. yeah all right so okay so
pick one and go with it you he you can
either you heard you heard me yeah under
25 or over 35. I've been wrong every
time it doesn't matter all right so
you're gonna say 24 and I like six I
like that you're the guy at the roulette
table just betting in both sides you
can't file you don't know if I'm up or
down you're voting red and black he's
voting ready I'm gonna go 32. 32 yeah
you said I'm Gonna Give You 36 what are
you or 23 not taking it under 25 over 24
36. so yeah I'll go what'd you say 36 27
32 I said 32 32 27 under 20 36 over 30
16. I changed
all right this dude uh unbelievable no
they didn't give his name okay they
didn't stick his picture up put his
picture and we'll get out of here on
this as we said once again
you will thank us for it this dude was
34 years old there you go Daniel oh
right under where he said I know we're
on the coast I was wrong twice well you
were kind of right like you were very
much on the edge I was over six today
guys oh for six and we only guessed
three times Neil Brennan thank you for
joining us on dumb people town we love
you dude in like every great writer's
room that you've ever been in where you
[__] around before you had to go to
work you're like oh [__] we gotta get
back to work
[Music]